was said that you took a nap during a
rain delay in the World Series I walked
in the clubhouse and the whole entire
Club was wrapped up I didn't want to see
that I was so like nervous the whole
entire month I had stomachache after
stomach ache you know
like it's the butterflies are just
constantly there and I went to the
weight room those um mattress that we
have in the weight room I just laid
there I was there for like 10 15 minutes
I got up and it was like all right how
did you get sleepy it's not about being
sleepy it's about putting your your body
and your mind in a different state where
you getting those out did you even
realize you fell asleep no it was one of
those where I was trying to like come
myself just lay down and all of a sudden
all right let's go let's go back to this
you're trying to calm down because
especially when you saw the clubhouse
being wrapped up you know what that
means yeah yeah